change yeah with this is pastor marlony
ladder 14 our coming your live audio
podcast
i don't know if you guys saw but there
was i finally saw a [ __ ] that show
saturday night live finally getting good
they finally hired a kid who knows what
he's talking about shane gillis
that's a funny kid right there yeah loud
yeah i beat a kid obviously works over
at the firehouse shane gillis is gonna
see a firefight and get some skit work
yeah it gets
get some skit work i did and then it's
nice it's nice to see the [ __ ] kids
coming out of the woodwork
um you know supporting him who just you
know who want their names to go viral in
articles shout out lewis gomez
yeah um right now we're uh we want to
say hello to all the hyena fans who have
been listening and who have been making
more hyenas spreading the word
we also want to say hello to whatever
internet blogger may be tuning in right
now yes
after me and chrissy got hired for
something yes hi how are you how's your
day
we know you're sitting there in your
little apartment okay you got three
roommates right now and you're
definitely eating
sabra hummus with carrots as you're
perusing these
um podcasts for slurs yeah now let me
just save you a little time
you're not gonna have to search too far
just keep listening to this podcast
because they are a come man yeah they're
coming and it's just
it doesn't with the chain out i think
it's inevitable yeah it's [ __ ] it's
just what's gonna happen okay
so yeah listen here's the truth to the
situation
okay i if you guys don't know shane
gillis
friend of the show great comedian happy
to see him get snl thank uh you know
he's a really funny [ __ ] kid
he said some uh slurs about
asians on a podcast two years ago some
ff seth simon i believe his name was
there's a few of them yeah
these kids they dug through the the they
dug through the trash to find the stuff
it's
whatever yeah you can't say those words
but it's also like
it's a podcast he's a comedian whatever
whatever i don't think for
a [ __ ] second not for a second
that lorne michaels and the people in
snl did not know that that was already
out
hired the other first asian higher bone
yang also congrats to him i've never met
him but heard good things about the kid
congrats to him that they didn't all
know that this was going to happen
and create a controversy in a stir to
get eyes and ears and get people writing
about
the upcoming season of snl i think that
the machine of snl
they know how to any press is good press
so you can't convince me that they
didn't already know this was out yeah
lauren's a screwed-in kid he's a
scrutiny kid and this kid who we hired
seth simon
he probably [ __ ] hired this kid and
he's just an ff that's yelling about
[ __ ] but it's like he's probably getting
money
from the snl machine yeah because
melissa visiting
she also got in trouble for herself
villa senorites billy
what did she say she said something she
got in trouble when she got it she's a
latina woman she's a latina woman so
it's like yeah what was it mikey
it wasn't sensitive tweets like racial
jokes and tweets yeah nothing
trevor noah had a few as well he's a
black kid from south africa
yeah it's just nobody cares the the
bottom line is nobody
it's all it's all part of the story
genuinely nobody cares nothing's going
to happen to shane he's not going to get
booed he's
very funny so i would expect him to do
exceptionally well on the show
but the bottom line is the truth is
nobody cares i was at the wicked monk
yesterday and bearish talking to some i
was talking to some girls
and you were also yeah wicked monk is a
place where a lot of scholars frequent i
mean it's like a real harvard bar yeah
it's a harvard bar and i was talking to
a couple of girls and they started
talking about the louis ck thing
and their consensus opinion was if
if a guy's jerking off on the phone you
hang up and if a guy's jerking off in
front of you
and he's not blocking the door then
you're throwing out a window dude you
throw him out a window yeah and you just
leave yeah so because most it's all it's
all [ __ ]
we're living in such as soon as all this
stuff came out with shane
and this i was like you know you guys
are getting in you went outside and
started staring down chinese yeah
starting yeah because it's like oh
tweet of yours thank you zach yeah tweet
if you support shane it's like yeah i do
support
shane the twitter b it's all [ __ ] if
you tweet something out
it's all [ __ ] it's like they're
you're just feeding this thing that's
not real yeah
nothing's gonna happen they also took it
out of context and also it's obviously
not really about
the morality because if it was then they
would have had this story come out
before he got hired for smell like
if you're uh first of all if you're a
professional
if you're if you cover comedy
professionally yeah
you're you're basically that's the open
mic scene for journalists
yeah you're a loser you're an open mic
journalist okay
um but if you're covering comedy aren't
you supposed to be doing field research
aren't you supposed to be writing these
articles before there's a big hire
why did you wait for him to get hired at
snl in order for this to come
out and another thing is listen listen
jokes exist in context right
okay imagine context good or bad jokes
good or bad by the way mike's wiping off
the laptop screen so you know what
happened on that laptop screen
earlier this morning late last night
when the kid has to wipe it off yeah he
shot some of his glue on from there yeah
the kid was glueing on the [ __ ]
laptop screen what it is it's just what
it is
slurpee on it yeah he got some slurpee
whatever you say is that what you call
your toothpaste these days
yeah yeah cuz you're a turkey with a
slurpee
[Music]
a turkey with a slurpee yeah i like it
yeah turkey with slurpee
for my fitness fans it's do some burpees
getting slurpee yeah or you're a burpee
with a slurpee we would love to have
some of our plus-sized fans send us
turkeys with a slurpee yeah just be
turkey with a slurpee show us your
[ __ ] fat gobble chin we're just like
chris we're just new york kids we're
just funny kids we're just funny screwed
in kids and i gotta pee again i have an
std yeah
and i need an impossible burger yeah
giannis may go
cut i may go down i'm a little
lightheaded oh that's an apple you may
have to move your seat behind yanny yeah
you may have to lay down and be the nets
yeah cuz i know you had a few of those
cupcakes
at sergio's birthday party it's what it
is it's what it is
and i like birthday cake where's uh
snowballs and ring dings yeah
was it truly yeah that's hilarious did
he do any cocaine in his own bathroom
not that he let us know were there any
pieces because puerto ricans
they have pieces in their family were
there a couple of pieces uh
none that were there did you breathe on
anybody yeah but not
on purpose yeah [ __ ] i love mike
emoji yeah
yeah he's a good [ __ ] kid great kid
and he gets it unlike he burns
doesn't get it zacky yeah
so jokes exist in context good or bad
jokes
right that's where they live in context
you can consider context like water
and jokes are like fish okay keep the
[ __ ] fish
in the water right you can't take a joke
out of context
you ever like talk to somebody and they
try to tell you something funny that
someone else said
right and then it doesn't work and they
go ah you had to be there
yeah you had to be there basically means
the joke's out of context yeah you
weren't there that's what a professional
comedian is
jokes exist in context on the podcast in
that moment
when you try to retell it it's not a
joke anymore it's a statement
yeah so just leave comedians alone
you're an open mic
journalist stay the [ __ ] away i
understand you've created a job for
yourself because all the important jobs
are taken writing about important stuff
yeah but we are just [ __ ] clowns
and you are acting like the snitch in
the front of the class do you understand
yeah you're not gonna stop us the people
don't care
there's enough of you because there's
not a lot of real jobs out there and you
don't want to work a real job
so there's enough of you to retweet and
like and comment on each other's posts
and that's why you think there's a scene
out there that cares about this [ __ ]
nobody cares
nobody [ __ ] cares this is america
people can say what they want and the
heartbeat of a free nation
is uncensored comedy do you know what
i'm playing right now what are you
playing the german national anthem
that's not what i thought it was
yeah cause you're saying some you're
making some german points right now no
i'm not you just [ __ ] kamikaze me
with a german national anthem i don't
want it i wanted you to play the stars
and strikes
germany